we're told the graph of y equals 2 to
the x is shown below all right
which of the following is the graph of y
equals 2 to the negative x minus 5. so
there's two changes here instead of 2 to
the x we have 2 to the negative x and
then we're not leaving that alone we
then subtract 5. so let's take them step
by step so let's first think about what
y equals 2 to the negative x will look
like
well any input we now put into it x
we're now going to take the negative of
it so if i input a 2 it's like taking
the opposite of the 2 and then inputting
that into 2 to the x
and so what we're essentially going to
do is flip this graph over the y axis
so here we have the point 2 comma 4.
over here we're going to have the point
negative 2
comma 4.
when x is 0 they're going to give us the
same value so they're both going to have
the same y-intercept and so our graph is
going to look like
our graph is going to look something
like
this they're going to be mirror images
flipped around the y-axis
and so
it's going to look it's going to look
like
that
that is the graph of y is equal to 2 to
the negative x and then we have to worry
about the subtracting 5 from it well
that's you're subtracting 5 from your
final y value so that's going to or
you're subtracting 5 to get your y value
now or your y value is going to be 5
lower is i guess the best way to say it
so this is going to shift the graph down
by 5. so instead of having the y
intercept there's going to be 5 lower 1
each hash mark is 2. so this is one two
three four five it's going to be right
over there so shift down by five two
four
five it's going to look like that and
then the asymptote instead of the
asymptote going towards y equals zero
the asymptote is going to be at y is
equal to negative five so the asymptote
is going to be
y equals negative five so it should look
something like
it should look something like something
like
what i'm drawing
right now so something like
something like that
so now we can look at which choices so
this this should be the graph of y
equals 2 to the negative x minus 5. so
let's see which of these choices depict
that
so this first choice actually seems to
be spot on it's exactly what we drew but
we could look at the other ones just in
case
well this is this looks like what did
they do over here it looks like they
instead of flipping over the
y-axis they took the they flipped over
the x-axis and then they shifted down so
that's not right
here it looks like they got what we got
but then they flipped it over the x-axis
and this looks like they flipped it over
the y-axis but then they shifted instead
of stitching down by five looks like
they shifted to the left by five so we
should feel pretty good especially
because we essentially drew this before
even looking at the choice